una úlcera péptica es una úlcera que se
desarrolla en la membrana de la parte
inferior de su esófago
o varias partes de su estómago o
intestino delgado
se conoce como úlcera esofágica aquella
úlcera péptica en su esófago y aquella
que se encuentra en el estómago se le
conoce como úlcera gástrica cuando la
úlcera afecta a la primera parte de su
intestino delgado llamado duodeno se le
conoce como úlcera duodenal cuando come
su estómago produce jugos digestivos
altamente ácidos también conocidos como
ácido gástrico para ayudar a procesar
los alimentos luego el alimento pasa a
su duodeno para más digestión y la
absorción siguiente en el torrente
sanguíneo
para ayudar a proteger sus órganos de
los efectos corrosivos del ácido
gástrico una capa mucosa cubre la
membrana de su estómago y duodeno
cuando la capa mucosa protectora se
rompe el ácido gástrico puede ingresar a
la membrana de su estómago o duodeno y
causar una úlcera
la mayoría de las úlceras pépticas son
causadas por una bacteria 'helicobacter
pylori' también conocida como h pylori
y los científicos creen que esta
bacteria puede ingresar a su organismo
mediante agua o alimento contaminado o
mediante un contacto cercano con una
persona infectada
una vez dentro de su organismo se
asientan en la capa mucosa de su
estómago o duodeno
a medida que la bacteria crece dañan la
capa mucosa lo que permite que el ácido
gástrico llegue al estómago o membrana
duodenal juntos el ácido gástrico y la
bacteria pueden causar una úlcera
algunas úlceras pépticas están asociadas
al abundante uso de medicamentos
antiinflamatorios no esteroideos también
conocidos como el ing
incluso la aspirina y el ibuprofeno
estos medicamentos reducen la capacidad
de su estómago y duodeno de protegerse
de los efectos del ácido gástrico
su médico puede recetar un medicamento o
una combinación de medicamentos para
tratar su úlcera péptica si la hache
pylori es la causa de su úlcera deberá
tomar antibióticos para matar a la
bacteria si su úlcera se debe a
medicamentos no esteroideos
antiinflamatorios su médico le
recomendará que detenga o limite el uso
de estos medicamentos para una úlcera
gástrica puede recibir un inhibidor de
la bomba de protones también conocido
como vp a fin de disminuir la producción
de ácido en su estómago para una úlcera
duodenal puede recibir un antagonista de
los receptores tipo 2 de histamina
conocida comúnmente como bloqueador h2
para reducir el monto de ácido segregado
en su estómago además su médico puede
recomendar medicamentos para cubrir y
proteger la membrana de su estómago y
duodeno
hasta que la úlcera haya sanado éstas
incluyen su cara el fato misoprostol y
subsal y trato de bismuto conocido
comúnmente como pepto bismol puede
requerir una cirugía para una úlcera que
no se sana con medicación
o puede requerir cirugía para una úlcera
que se disipa con el tratamiento cuando
es recurrente
puede necesitar una cirugía para una
úlcera que sangra
si su úlcera rompe o perfora la pared de
su estómago o duodeno puede necesitar
una cirugía para reparar el daño
también puede necesitar cirugía para una
úlcera que impide que los alimentos se
muevan de su estómago si tiene una o más
de estas complicaciones su médico puede
recomendar uno de los tres
procedimientos quirúrgicos siguientes
una vago tome a andrew tome a o píloro
plastía
en una vago tome a su cirujano cortar
aparte de su nervio vago a través de
este nervio su cerebro le dice al
estómago que libere ácido después de que
su cirujano corte el nervio su estómago
se agregara menos ácido
en una andrés tomini a su cirujano
eliminar a la parte inferior de su
estómago conocido como antro el antro
avisa a su estómago que libere ácido
una vez eliminado su estómago libera
menos ácido
si su úlcera está bloqueando la salida
de alimentos de su estómago su cirujano
puede realizar una píloro plastía
durante este procedimiento su cirujano
ensanchará el píloro que es la abertura
entre su estómago y el duodeno lo que
permite que el alimento atraviese con
más facilidad
mientras se cura su úlcera debe evitar
el consumo de alcohol y cigarrillos esto
se debe a que puede retardar el proceso
de curación y puede empeorar su úlcera
unas pocas semanas posteriores al
tratamiento su médico puede realizar una
endoscopia que es un procedimiento para
mirar dentro del tracto digestivo
superior para asegurarse de que su
úlcera se ha sanado